nobody does halloween like the
kardashian jenners it's never a dull
moment over the weekend the famous
family went all out for the spooky
holiday and we mean all out i'm just
like living life kourtney kardashian and
her fiance travis barker were feeling
the romance literally celebrating their
first halloween as an engaged couple by
paying tribute to the cult classic crime
flick true romance
i'm a married man buddy
man you want to say hello to my better
hands come here the lovebirds documented
their costumes on instagram sunday
dressed as the main characters from the
1993 drama that's the blink 182 drummer
crushing it as christian slater's
character clarence complete with a wig
and all of his tats covered up and
that's court as patricia arquette's
character alabama hot pink animal print
hot pants included
really cute both court and travis posted
a photoshopped poster along with a quote
from the movie that read in part quote
you're so cool you're so cool you're so
cool
that three words went through my mind
endlessly repeating themselves
like a broken record
you're so cool
[Music]
you're so cool
you're so cool
court also posted clips and pics from
her house which was decorated to the
nines for a halloween dinner we're
talking giant skeletons lots of pumpkins
floating witch hats a witch's cauldron
twinkly lights and a creepy tablescape
oh and if all that wasn't festive enough
that's court and her man posing as
frankenstein and his bride
i love it the pooch founder also took a
trip to the pumpkin patch with her kids
as for chloe well she's quarantining at
home with her daughter true after
announcing they both tested positive for
kovid 19 last week but before they
learned they were under the weather coco
told ellen degeneres they planned to
have a cute mommy daughter costume
moment true's gonna be moana
and she wants me to be pua the pig
so
it's a little shady of her but that's
okay i will be pua for true you're a
good mother i will be pua for true it's
unclear if the good american founder
ended up dressing up as pua at home but
her three-year-old wore an adorable
little maui outfit for this pick it's
such a beautiful thing
as for kylie she posted this family pic
with her beau travis scott and their
daughter stormi writing that this year
she was quote in full mommy mode that's
travis as michael myers and stormy as a
mermaid riding in a golf cart and
there's kylie posing with her mom kris
jenner the makeup mogul's baby bump on
full display
so what did chris dress up as
let me see mom
you are a fendi skimmed catwoman
and grandma you're a witch
i'm so here for that momager moment
rocking kim's skins
the shapewear designer hosted a
halloween party with the family complete
with an indoor smoke machine
monochromatic pumpkins a mummy a bounce
house a slime station and the cutest
table for the kids and her kiddos
costumes were the cutest sam went as a
truck driver north dressed as a goth
girl saint was a pet from the game adopt
me while chicago dressed as a cute
little witch
i don't know what's gonna top that
as for kendall she threw her annual
halloween slash birthday party dressed
as martian girl from mars attacks
hi there
are you interested in the white house in
attendance justin and haley bieber
but perhaps the best costume of the
night the weeknd who was totally
unrecognizable dressed as the godfather
i'm gonna make them an awfully camera
few
[Music]
you